okay so can anybody hear me on this
livestream here I'm just getting
situated and I just wanted to oh thanks
and I appreciate that she says I love
your channel great pinko says I needed
this okay great
yeah can you hear me can everyone hear
me what I'm saying here yeah you can
hear me okay great Carlos is with us
okay good well so today what I was
thinking we could do is just go over
some important formulas you want to know
for Tina's here welcome Tina Kaori yep
okay good you can hear me okay great so
yeah so what I thought we could do is
maybe just talk about the acte a little
bit okay Anacin you make math fun again
because I hated masks so much oh good
I'm glad that my videos are helping you
Anna that's great so what I thought we
could do is maybe just go through some
formulas and then what I want to do is
just open it up for questions so that
you know things that you want to talk
about you know we can talk about
together and just kind of help everybody
out here I do want to let everybody know
that I do have that a CT math review
video course that's available for sale
through the about page on my youtube
channel and I've got a link for that in
the description so if you're interested
it goes through 65 concepts and you know
we discuss some different types of
problems that you know you will
encounter when you take the a CT math
section so check that out there's some
free previews there so you can see if
it's something you're interested in but
let's jump into this video here now and
so the first thing I wanted to do is
just kind of go through some of the
basic formulas so does everybody know
your distance formula okay so definitely
something you want to know it's X 2
minus X 1 the quantity squared right
plus y 2 minus y 1 the quantity squared
you add those two together and you take
the square root and that's your distance
so definitely memorize this one if you
don't have it already
another important formula you want to
know is your midpoint formula right so a
midpoint we've got X 1 plus X 2 divided
by 2 right and you add the Y coordinates
together and you divide by 2
ok so as I'm going through these think
of some questions and things that you
want to talk about or ask me but I'm
just going to write down a few formulas
of it you know I think that everyone is
going to want to know also you want to
know your average formula right
when you go to find an average you know
what is an average well it's the total
you know okay Tina says couldn't you
also do Pythagorean theorem yeah
absolutely Tina you're absolutely right
you can instead of using the distance
formula you can use the Pythagorean
theorem and I'll show you how that works
as we just kind of write down a few more
of these formulas but so the average is
an important formula and so what you do
is you take the total divided by a
however many you have so like if you're
trying to find your average in your math
class you would add up all the points
from your test divided by the number of
tests that you took and that's going to
be your average rate okay so we've got
our distance we've got our midpoint
we've got our average what about our
slope formula definitely want to know
the slope formula that's going to be
your y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1 or you
can think of it as your rise over your
run right so that's another important
formula another important formula
sometimes students forget but this is an
easy one to get right when you take the
AC T and that's your circle formula okay
so let me see if I can just write that
one down for us it's X minus H squared
plus y minus K squared equals the radius
squares okay
so cahuachi says I have issues with this
question can you help me please which
one is it the circle question Anna says
I have to take precalc and calc also
physics one and two can you do
one-on-one with students yeah I can do
one-on-one with students for precalc
you know I tutor students like in my
local area like basically algebra
algebra to geometry precalculus a CT SAT
math you know trigonometry so all those
areas I mainly focus on so yeah if you
need help if anyone's interested in
one-on-one tutoring online or you know
via FaceTime we can certainly set
something up just contact me through my
um through my about page or through my
website Mario's math tutoring com but
here we're just writing down some
formulas that we all want to know for
the acct coming up right on Saturday
right so let's see we've got the
distance midpoint average slope circle
equation you know there's been another
form of that's been popping up a little
bit and that's the expected value does
everybody know what expected value is
it's basically what you do
and is saying I live in New Jersey I
need those courses to get into the PT
program okay physical therapy program
okay good yeah so definitely want to
make sure you get good scores there but
yeah so expected value what you do is
you know you take the probability okay
that an event occurs and then you
multiply by the value of that event and
then what you do is you sum those up and
that's your expected value so you might
see something like that on the on the
test it's called expected values okay
Tina says okay yes I'll see you but tune
has hi from Turkey and I want to prepare
for the acct but my English is not
enough I think you can help me guys
maybe create a CT class whatsapp group
okay so I'm not so familiar with
whatsapp group but definitely something
maybe you guys want to check out so yeah
so we're just kind of going through some
other formulas here or any other formula
that you guys can think of that you
think would be important to mention here
in this little formula sheet I'm just
thinking through this we've got distance
midpoint average slope circle equation
expected value and the other ones that
you think that maybe I'm missing of
course there's all kinds of formulas you
know of course you want to know your
equation of a line right so you want to
know your y equals MX plus B that's not
so much a formula though I think as far
as you know you also want to know your
point-slope formula that's helpful as
well when you're writing equations of
lines but any other formulas that you
think that are important besides these
ones of course you want to know all your
you want to know all your sine cosine
and tangent ratios with right triangles
you want to know your 30 60 90 and
45-45-90 triangles those are important
oftentimes referred to as yep Cana st.
Pythagorean theorem yeah I definitely
wanna know your Pythagorean theorem a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
also good to know
let's see you are saying where when and
where to use the R squared formula well
that's the circle equation we can talk
about that in a minute obtain a same
quadratic formula that's also a good one
let's add that to the list here so
quadratic formula I'm just writing these
down maybe you guys can write these down
as I'm writing these too so you can have
them for your notes but a quadratic
formula you use when you have an
equation that's in this form equal to
zero and what you do is you do the
opposite of b plus or minus
the square root of b squared minus 4ac
all divided by 2a
okay tain is saying if they give you the
radius of the circle you have to square
it yeah that's exactly right so here
let's talk about the circle for a minute
because that everybody seems to be
interested in the circle equation
because that's an easy one to get get
get right and get an extra point on your
test right so here let's do an example
so let's say for example you have say
the center of your circles at negative
two comma one and say the radius equals
four so the equation of this circle
would be what it's going to be X plus
two squared plus y minus one squared
equals 16 okay so now that here's where
students kind of go off a little bit see
how this is like plus two right here
it's the opposite right so if it's minus
two you actually want to add two and
then square that quantity and then same
thing over here
okay Frank's saying interest equations
okay that's a good one yeah let's write
that one down too I'll write that one
down after I explain about the circle so
then yeah y minus 1 the quantity squared
so notice again see how this is negative
one but the y coordinate is positive one
so these are going to be the opposite
signs and then of course over here you
have the radius squared so I'll just do
one more circle example and we'll talk
about that interest equation say they
give you the equation of a circle and
say it's like this X minus 7 squared
plus y squared equals 49 so can anybody
tell me what the center of this circle
is and what the radius is so what do you
think what's the center and what's the
radius of this circle this is the kind
of thing that you could you know likely
see on the test and again it's an easy
problem to get right so you just where
is the center and what's the radius
anybody I don't want to chime in
ok radius is let's see seven Mikko says
ok yeah as me go right
yeah but tune is saying it from Turkey
is saying 7 ok
is he right yeah you guys are right guys
and gals you guys are right so and what
about the center where is the center of
the circle well that's a good question
well remember it's the opposite right so
if this is X minus seven this is going
to be positive seven this is y minus
zero or plus zero keep a tune is saying
a seven zero your
right so seven comma zero with the
radius of seven
so again circles definitely something
you want to you know review if you don't
know this formula already of course
everything that I'm talking about in
this live stream I have videos covering
all these different topics so if you
just go to my channel go to the little
magnifying glass a search
symbol and go ahead and type these
concepts in there on my channel I've got
videos on all of this
ok Ryan's laughing out loud ok so yeah
we were talking about that other
equation the interest equation so
remember this is also an important
formula when you talk about compound
interest equals P one plus R over N to
the NT right so remember the P is the
principal that's what you put in right
that's what you start with ok and then R
is the interest rate okay so if it's 5%
you want to convert that to a decimal
0.05 and is the number of times that you
compound in a year so if it's like
quarterly and it would be 4 if its
weekly and it would be 52 if it's you
know annually then that's just once a
year and would be 1 and then of course T
time is the number of years but you know
another equation it's kind of related to
this ok when you talk about exponential
equations exponential equations are in
this form a B to the X power right
oftentimes what they'll do is they'll
say you know write a model or write an
equation you know that such that it's
like an exponential growth or
exponential decay and they'll just say
that they'll give you the rate so for
example okay let's see o'clock you
saying consider the functions f of X
equals square root of x and G of x
equals 7x oops let me see if I can lost
that one there let me see your whoops
let's see I lost that ok there it is
yeah and in the standard XY coordinate
plane F of G of X passes through 4 6
what does the value of B is it a 8 is it
C negative 25 DNA fit yeah we can talk
about that question in in just a second
let's see if we can go through this one
first ok so basically what we have here
is the equation I was going to show you
as a equals p1 plus or minus R to the T
right so P is what you start with like
say you have like a car and it's $30,000
right and it's going
down in value by 20% per year you would
use one minus 0.2 zero and then T would
be the number of years so if it's three
years you know you put three in for the
time and you could solve of course if
it's going up in value then you'd be
adding whatever the rate of growth is so
again in this live stream we're just
going through some important formulas
you want to know and we're going to open
it up for questions if you guys are
enjoying this if you give me a thumbs up
on the video I'd appreciate that if you
like it if you don't like it give me a
thumbs in town right but I hope you're
liking it and then you know the more you
participate I think the more that you'll
get out of it and the more everybody
will benefit as well so yeah definitely
feel free to jump in and the other thing
I wanted to mention - I think I
mentioned at the very beginning is that
if you're interested in learning more
about all this AC t-- math you can check
out my AC t-- math huge review video
course it's available through my about
page on my youtube channel that's for
sale goes through 65 different concepts
a lot of example problems a lot of
opportunities to boost your score in the
test through through the experience you
gain in that course a lot of students
have taken it a lot of my subscribers
have taken it and they've said that it's
really helped their score so check that
out and there's some free previews on
there that you can check out as well and
I have a link in that description of
this livestream so if you want go ahead
and take a look at that as well
but let me see if I can go back to that
question that kolache I don't know if
I'm pronouncing that correctly so let's
see he said consider the functions f of
X equals square root of x okay let me
see if I can write this down here the
live the live chats disappears kind of
quick on me here so see f of X equals
square root of x and then he says that G
of x equals 7x okay let's see so then
they're asking what's F of G of X and it
passes through the point 4 comma 6 so I
can write this down here what's the
value of B oh okay this is let me see
here I'm not sure if I got this quite
right is this G of X equals 7 X this is
7 X minus B o'clock E is it 7 X minus B
over here is it 7 x equals B I think you
have equals on there
well you know let me just answer this
question just in a general way like see
here's the thing like when you do a
composition of functions this is also
something important to know for the test
so definitely a good question but what
you do and you do these composition of
functions is you're putting one function
into the other function so if it's the
way that I've written it so far I think
I don't quite understand the question
exactly how it's written in that and the
comment there but basically attaint is
saying should you try to play plug G of
X into the f of X function okay and then
clock is saying that this is 7x plus B
okay so yeah so that's exactly right
what you would do is you would put 7x
plus B okay in for G of X right then
this 7x plus B is going into X into f of
X function so this is then going to be
square root of seven X plus B okay and
let's see so and then that was equal to
let's see it was equal to six which is
the Y value that's the output and then
four that's the x value that's the input
so if we simplify this down it looks
like this is going to be 28 plus B
equals six
unfortunately my my be kind of looks
like a six but you square both sides you
get 36 and that's 28 plus B and then of
course if you subtract 28 from both
sides B is equal to 8 so that should be
the the correct answer there I hope that
answers your question
kolache so that's a good question though
you know composition of functions
definitely something you want to be
familiar with on the on the AC T and
again remember the key to these
functions it's like this say your
function is just all your welcome
clockey says thanks ok good see just
remember the key to these functions is
whatever's in here goes in place for X
on the right that's the key so like even
if they said f of cat ok just to be
funny okay they would put CA T in place
of X minus 1 ok so whatever is in the
parentheses that goes in for X on the
right side of the equation and you
simplify so what do you think is
everyone enjoying this live stream I
know everyone's getting ready to take
the test on Saturday it's going to be a
big day I know it's the end of the
school year for a lot of students but
what other questions do you want to ask
me
if you're enjoying this livestream give
it a thumbs up and if you have questions
go ahead and feel free to jump in and
you know ask them here and I'm just
encouraging everyone to check out my a
CT math review video course it's called
a huge a CT math review video course a
lot of students have taken it a lot of
students have benefitted it's boosted
their score and said that it was a
really good way of reviewing a lot of
important concepts and even learning
some things that they hadn't learned
maybe in their math class or had
forgotten so definitely go and check
that out it's I've got a link in the
description to this livestream and I
also have it on my about page there's a
link there on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring or you can go to my
website Mario's math tutoring comm and I
also just wanted to mention if you're
interested in online tutoring or if you
want to do like some facetiming with me
okay
Tina's asking about inequalities and
complicated inequalities yeah we can
talk about that Tina but yeah if you're
interested in one-on-one just online
tutoring with me if you want to prepare
if you've got some questions and some
things you want to go over some problems
you want to do together this is a little
bit limited because it's more like you
can chat and stuff like that but when we
do it online we see each other we both
can access like a whiteboard a shared
whiteboard so we cannot you know see
what each other is writing it's a little
bit more interactive or we can do a live
stream if you're like an Apple user and
you have an iPhone or an iPad so okay
are you saying thank you for sharing a
part of your life with us well I'm glad
you're enjoying this you know it's it's
a lot of fun I enjoy it and you know
there's a ton of videos on my website if
you just go to my website now my website
but my youtube channel Mario's math
tutoring you'll see a lot of videos on a
CT and SAT math so but yeah I just want
to try to see if we can do some more
promised together here so Tina was
saying that she wanted to talk about
inequalities and complex complicated
inequality as well here's a complicated
inequality for you can you guys see this
okay is it clear
Jesse's asking please what are questions
to expect yeah so we're kind of talking
about some of the formulas right now
Jesse you can maybe go back to the
beginning the live stream we talked
about some of the formulas but Tina was
just asking about some more complicated
inequalities and here's kind of a
complicated inequality this is an
absolute value inequality and sometimes
students get a little bit confused of
when this is less than versus when this
is greater
then so let me see if I can show you two
of these problems so basically what you
would do here when it's less than it
means this quantity here is less than
four
of course you're taking the absolute
value which means that you know this
whole quantity is actually always going
to be made positive right once you take
the absolute value so what you do with
these problems like like so as you say
3x minus 2 okay Tina says look up
practice ACD problems and those will
give you a general gist Jessie okay yeah
you know what there if you want another
resource you know you can go to them get
the a CT like the real a CT guide
there's five practice tests in there and
you can also go to the 2016-2017
official a CT guy they've got some
formally released tests there that's the
best way to get some really good
practice with the actual problems aside
from you know that video course that I
have for sale where I talk about a lot
of the problems that expect you to know
but here we're just doing a compound
inequality the Tina was asking about and
so you can see okay clock is asking
another question integer from 100
through 999 inclusive is to be chosen at
random what is it probably the number
chose won't have zero it as at least the
one digit okay we can take a look at
that one in a minute but let's see if we
can solve this one so when you solve
these compound inequalities you want to
get the variable by itself in the in the
middle here so you want to add two to
the to the left the middle and the right
okay so when you do that you get
negative two is less than three X is
less than six then you just want to
divide everything by three right because
you want to get that x value by itself
and so you can see that X has to be in
between negative 2/3 and two so if
you're graphing this on the number line
right so you'd have negative 2/3 would
be here two would be here and X would be
in between those two values so does that
make sense
Tayna that's that's one type of
inequality and the thing is you know
what makes the inequalities in a little
bit more challenging and sometimes what
they do on the ECG is is this kind of a
scenario right here where you know
they're going to give you something like
negative 4x plus 8 is greater than 16
for example right so of course you it's
just like solving an equation you want
to get that variable by itself
but what happens when you divide or
multiply by a negative number
well I'm sure most of you know but you
know when you divide or multiply by a
negative number that inequality sign
actually flips okay so it becomes X is
less than negative two so that's the key
sometimes they do try to trick you with
that just making sure that you remember
that from your math class divide or
multiply by negative the sign flips but
let's see Clocky was asking a question
and so I encourage you guys if you have
guys and gals if you have a question you
know go ahead and write them in the
comment and you know we can talk about
those different types of problems but
let me see if I can not understand what
clock you was saying in this problem
here I'll see if I can bring that back
up so he's saying an integer from 100
throughout 999 inclusive so I'm meaning
including 100 and including 999 right
okay is to be chosen at random okay so
this is like a probability question so
probability is definitely something
important you want to know for the acct
a little bit more basic type of a
problem you know they don't really make
it too tricky the probability once but
just understanding that's another
formula by the way that you everybody
wants to make sure that they know what
what exactly is probability well
remember probability it's the number of
successes right number of successes
divided by what the total possible
outcomes right so I'm just abbreviating
a little bit here but yeah definitely
probability is important one to to know
like a simple example you know you have
a hat you've got two red marbles you've
got three blue marbles what's the
probability you pick a red marble right
that's a pretty basic question you know
but in this case there's two chances of
success out of five total so you know
your probability is going to be to fist
pretty basic but but let's go back to
calacas question I want to make sure we
kind of see if we can address that so an
integer from 109 hundred ninety nine
inclusive to be chosen at random what is
it probably the number chosen will have
zero as at least one digit so it was
probably the number chosen while at
least zero as at least one digit okay so
you know this is an interesting question
you know why it's an interesting
question because you have to go about it
and kind of a roundabout way so we're
really talking about a three digit
number here right
and so clock is wandering you know at
least one of these digits has to be zero
so one could be zero two could be zero
all three could be zero but why don't we
figure out how many of these three-digit
numbers don't have any zeros right so
what we're going to do is going to do
the probability that none have zeros
right okay so how many choices are there
for this first digit well
there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 right and then
how many choices are for the second
digit well normally there is going to be
0 through 9 which is 10 digits but we
don't want it to be a 0 so this is going
to be 9 and then over here the same
thing we want this one to be 0 through 9
but we don't want to be 0 so there's
just 9 choices you normally would be 10
you know but we're subtracting 1 because
we don't want it to be a 0 so what's 9
times 9 times 9 well it's 729 right so
basically what you would do then is
you'd say that the probability of it
let's see of not having any zeros would
be 729 out of well let's see how many
numbers are there from 100 to 999
well there's 900 right so I'd be 900 but
Kane is jumping in she's saying should
you subtract the none that have zeros by
1 yeah that's exactly right so we're
going to do one which represents a
hundred percent - what we don't want
okay which is the probability that you
know it doesn't have any zeros we'll
leave it will leave the probability that
it has one zero or more so if you do
this what do you get 1 minus 729 over
did I say whoops over 900 right so what
is 1 minus 729 over 900 well it's a
hundred and seventy-one over 900 so that
would be your probability right there
okay so did that answer your question
clock I don't know if I I got that so
basically that's the key you go about it
in a roundabout way you look at what you
don't want and then you do 1 minus what
you don't want that leaves the left over
which is what you did want there so
that's using a complement what they call
a complement so let's see sk-10 our bo i
says question 22 from the may tooth
and 5 3 H simplify fully 2 divided by X
minus 1 plus X minus 11 divided by x
squared plus 3 X minus 4 it might just
be the amount of numbers in that making
it look hard ok so that's a good
question let me see if I can write this
down really quick and everybody that's
here listening if you're enjoying this
live stream you know be sure to give it
a thumbs up if you're not liking it give
it a thumbs down either way just be
honest and if you have questions you
know feel free to jump in here and ask
your questions about these a CT
questions so that you can benefit and
everybody listening can benefit and
we're just kind of having them having
some fun here before the before the SAT
which is coming off the Saturday right
did I say SAT a CT sorry
a CT SAT was last Saturday ok so we've
got 2 over X minus 1 plus X minus 11
over s x squared plus 3 X minus 4 so
sk-10 our Bo I did I did I get the
question correct how did i do on that
one so so basically the key to this
problem and this is something you really
want to know for the a CT and and that's
that you really want to know your
factoring ok so a lot of students are
not so great at factoring and that makes
it a little bit difficult and I do have
a my math to channel Mario's math
tutoring I do have a nice video I think
it's about 20 minutes long going through
all the different types of factoring
whether it's factoring by grouping or
whether it's you know difference of two
squares or factoring trinomials you know
and Ryan C Anderson single yes factoring
please so there's a lot factoring is
like a big topic and so you definitely
want to know like difference of two
cubes and sum of two cubes and but some
of the main ones are just like like the
one I just did right here so X plus 4
times X minus 1 so if you want to add
these together this one has an X minus 1
but it's missing what an X plus 4 right
okay so that means that we have to
multiply the numerator and denominator
by X plus 4 right and then S chin is
saying is completing the square on the
AC T well that's a good question you
know it's ok it's not necessarily
completing the square but solving
quadratic equations is so you could do
that by
factoring you could do it by quadratic
formula you could do it by graphing so
there's a lot of different ways to solve
quadratic equations and completing the
square is just one of those techniques
so not absolutely necessary but
sometimes it can be helpful you know as
up maybe a quicker way to solve a
quadratic so basically you know this is
what we're doing is we're just combining
a combining these two fractions we had
to get a common denominator so that's
going to give us 2x plus 8 plus X minus
11 all over that common denominator X
plus 4 X minus 1 and then let's see so
2x plus 1 X is 3x and 8 minus 11 is
minus 3 oh I see where this is going
with this problem see what's happening
here is you want to factor this further
by factoring out the greatest common
factor see how I factored out a 3 and
then what do you notice here does
anybody see what's happening what's
going on here you see what's happening
sk-10 rbo i well notice what's the
numerator in the denominator of 8 so
what's happening or anything you notice
with the numerator and denominator well
the X minus ones those are going to
cancel so your numerator and denominator
and you're just left with 3 over X plus
4 whoops 3 over X plus 4 so that's your
final answer on that one so yeah you can
cancel them out yeah because they're
multiplied together see if they're
multiplied like this this is like
division and multiplication and division
are inverses so they cancel so yeah good
question so if anyone's just you know
joining us right now you know this is
Mario of course with Mario's math
tutoring and we're just going through
some formulas that you know you want to
know for the AC T math and I'm also
promoting my huge AC T math review video
course which goes through 65 different
concept areas that are covered on the AC
T and there's like three and a half
hours of video and we go through
examples together and we talk about
different problems that you would likely
see and so definitely check that out if
you go into the description of this
livestream or if you go to the about
page Maya Mario's math tutoring YouTube
channel or if you go to my website
Mario's math tutoring com you can check
this out and see some of the free
previews and see if it's a good fit for
you
so that's for sale through any of those
different avenues but it's called a huge
a CT math review video course okay so
let's see we had some other questions
come in as I was rambling on about a hum
my video course right let's see s shin
was talking about arithmetic sequences
okay Tina's saying she's got to go
thanks okay all right SIA Tina will see
another time but yeah we're going to
talk a little bit about arithmetic
sequences so hmm so when you talk about
arithmetic sequences you're basically
talking about something like this 3 7 11
15 19 dot dot right and an example might
be you know what's the let's just say
the 20th term in this sequence well you
know one way to do it is just to keep
following this pattern until you get to
the 20th term but that might take a
little bit of time especially if they
wanted the hundredth term but I'll give
everyone a chance what do you think is
there what would you do to get to that
to that hundredth term or in this case
let's just do the 20th term so a sub 20
any ideas how would you get to that 20th
term so as Shin is asking about
arithmetic sequences so what makes it an
arithmetic sequence is that you're
adding or subtracting the same thing
each time to get to the next term so can
anybody tell me what we're adding or
subtracting to get to the to the next
term in the sequence what do you guys
and gals think what are we doing to get
to the next term are we Caesar says to
ah let's see we're adding or subtract
all cases for Jessie says for Miko says
for Frank says for yeah you guys are
right it's it's four so what we're going
to do now so you think about it this way
you're starting at three right
that's your first term and you're adding
four how many times 19 times
how come 19 well you're already at the
first term so then you only have to add
4 one less times so basically what this
comes out to is what this is 76 plus 3
is 79 now if you want a formula here's
your formula it's a sub N equals a sub 1
plus D times n minus 1 a 1 is your first
term D is what you're adding that's
called a common differ
that's what you're adding to get to the
next term and you're adding that common
difference one less time than the term
that you want to get to that makes sense
so that's your formula with this this
live stream is devoted to the theme is
you know formulas for the AC T we're
talking about different kinds of
formulas that you want to know things
you may have forgotten or things that
you want to go over and talk about but
so I hope that answered your question s
chin what do you think was that was that
helpful is that kind of what you were
looking for the other problem that
sometimes you come across is like say
they wanted to ask you what are the some
of the first 20 terms well if you want
to find the sum of the first 20 terms
what you would do is you take the first
term okay plus the last term in this
case it's 79 okay times the number of
terms which is 20 divided by 2 so again
if you want a formula your formula is
going to look like this it's n divided
by 2 a sub 1 plus a sub n hoops I ran
out of room there but basically it's the
number of terms divided by 2 times the
sum of the first term plus the last term
and that gives you the sum and an
arithmetic series a series means that
you're adding them all together so yeah
we're at the half an hour mark and I'd
be happy to do some more practice
problems with everyone so just let me
know you know kind of questions you
might have or things you might want to
talk about again we're kind of talking
about formulas and important concepts
and formulas that you want to know for
the acct math section and my name is
Mario with Mario's math tutoring I think
you guys all know that but if you're
interested you know check out my check
out my channel I've got a lot of videos
talking about a CT math a lot of videos
talking about SAT math and then if
there's specific concepts that you want
to talk about more you know I can do
videos on those in the future let's see
Jessie says please can you go for more
of arithmetic sequences ok and Carlos
says thank you so much ok you're welcome
Carlos so yeah so arithmetic sequences I
mean I could show you another example
kind of like that and I mean like a
story problem would be something like
this like I think if I remember for one
of the old tests it said something like
you know somebody gets a sales job and
the first day they make like you know 25
calls and then
day after they make like ten additional
calls right so so that means that the
next the next day would be like you know
35 calls and that 45 calls and
fifty-five calls and dot dot dot so then
they might say well how many you know
sales calls is this person going to make
on the thirtieth day right so we're
looking for a sub thirty right Jesse so
again the pattern is you know you say
well you know the first the first term
is twenty five right and so we're
starting at twenty five and we're adding
ten how many times well to get to the
thirtieth term we're adding ten twenty
nine times so this is going to be two
hundred and ninety plus 25 which is
three hundred and fifteen so on that he
keeps up this pace or she keeps up this
pace she's going to making three hundred
fifteen sales calls on that thirtieth
day at the end of the month right so
they keep ramping up each day but again
you know where am I getting all this
information from I'm taking that first
term
okay walrus has got a good question here
for us okay we'll look at that one in
just one second but let me just finish
this one and we'll talk about that so a
sub N equals a 1 plus D the common
difference times n minus 1 and so Jessie
saying how did I get 29 oh that's a good
question Jessie well see what it is if
you're using the formula you take the
first term plus the common difference
which is 10 because we kept adding 10 to
get to the the next term right but you
only have to do that not 30 times but
just 29 times because so you even look
at this simple example right here see 1
2 3 4 5 to get to the fifth term if I'm
already at 25 I'm just adding 10 once
twice 3 times 4 times say I'm only
adding it four times even though that
this is the fifth term so it's always
going to be 1 less than the term that
you want so you start off at 25 and so
that's that's the idea so yeah so
basically that's the idea so let's see
you know somebody else had a question is
it bright enough can we see I'm trying
to get the light a little bit better
here so it's clear okay so yeah so let's
look at that last question let's see
Shin was asking us Shin at a local post
office oh there was one before that lets
see walras the sum of two positive
numbers is
151 the lesser number is 19 more than
the square root of the greater number
what is the value of the greater number
minus the lesser number okay you know
what role versus bringing up okay
walruses bring up an important concept
here and that's that you definitely want
to understand systems of equations
there's always systems of equations
problems on the AC T and the SAT and
there's different ways to solve those
you can do substitution you can do a
lamination there's different you know
graphing method course if they give you
the answers you can always try back
substitution is a good technique a lot
of different ways to solve it but let's
just let's just see if I can write these
equations down so it says at a local at
the wrong line let's see where is that
one there it is okay the sum of two
positive numbers so let's call one
number X right let's call the other
number y the sum means you're adding
together and you get a hundred and fifty
one right okay then it says the lesser
number let's just make Y the lesser
number right is 19 more okay then the
square root of the greater number so if
you take the square root of the greater
number and let's see the lesser number
is 19 more so let's see the that means
the lesser number is 19 more than the
square root of the greater number what
is the value of the greater number minus
the lesser number okay that's a good
question yes I like that question that's
a really makes you think so so basically
what we have here is we've got two
equations these used two right here
right and so how do we solve this well
what I would do for this problem is I
would probably use the substitution
method and what I would do here is I
would I would rearrange this equation to
solve for y so I'm going to subtract X
from both sides so that means y equals
150 one minus X then what I would do is
I would take this quantity right here
right and I would put it in place of Y
that's the substitution okay so now
we've got a hundred 251 minus X equals
square root of x plus 19 okay now what
do we want to do well now what you want
to do is you want to get the square root
by itself so I'm going to subtract 19
from both sides but I gave us a tough
problem
Oris this is a
this is a tough one I don't have my
calculator with me let's see so I think
I might actually behind me somewhere but
let's see so this is a what does that
come out to that's 132 is that right
okay minus X equals square root of x
okay then what you want to do is you
want to square both sides Square this
side square this side right but the
problem is is you're going to have to
foil this out okay so I'm just going to
tell you how to do it you're going to
foil this out and you want to get
everything on one side set it to zero
factor to set the factors to zero once
you do that okay then you can see which
one's the positive answer because these
are just positive numbers you can put it
back in here to find out what Y is then
you'll know what x and y are and then
you can subtract to find the difference
so I guess I'm going to leave it at this
point here just because these numbers
are going to get pretty large I just
don't have my calculator right with me
at the moment so other questions other
things you want to talk about let's see
oh okay well verse says I forgot to foil
it okay thanks you're welcome okay so
okay let's see so all right so let's see
here let's see all right so basically
let's take a look so right now I just
want to just take a moment here if
you're just joining live stream and you
have questions or you want to talk about
some concepts or some problems that
you're going to see on a CT math section
you know feel free to to jump in and ask
those questions but I just wanted to
promote my huge a CT math review video
course that I have for sale on my
website at Mario's math tutoring comm or
through the link in my about page on my
Morrow's mastering YouTube channel or I
have a Lincoln that should be a link in
the description of this livestream so if
you're interested check that out there's
some free previews if it's right for you
you know consider getting that a lot of
students have taken it and said it's
really helped them boost the score you
know their score on the math section of
a CT so I highly recommend that and if
you're interested in one-on-one tutoring
like online tutoring we can certainly do
that and
soccer heads asking how many answers you
have to get right on the math section to
pass well that's not really like a pass
or fail thing it's more of like you know
certain colleges are looking for certain
scores and obviously the better that you
do you know it's a there's a you can get
36 total is a scale basically so if you
get a 36 that's considered a perfect
score but there's 60 questions 60
minutes it's multiple choice so you can
use some back substitution techniques to
you know to check your to check to see
if you got the right answer and yeah so
basically that's that's the idea there
so let's see here okay so yeah so if
there's any other question okay my
colleges asking for 18 or higher okay
all right so 18 or higher definitely
definitely doable so I mean 18 is is
definitely doable a lot of students try
to get up into that thirty range or some
students have 27 or 28 is their goal
some students have 35 it just depends on
you know where you're going what you're
studying and you know how much math
you've taken up to this point but so
let's see so other questions let me look
back at the chat here it kind of scrolls
by kind of quick and sometimes I miss
some of them so let's see some of these
questions I might not necessarily answer
because it might not you know let's see
Miko says if five times the number n is
subtracted from 15 the result is
negative which is the possible value for
n/a only three only 10 only or yeah so I
basically let's see if we can write this
one down Miko so basically it says five
times a number and is subtracted from
fifteen okay
the result is negative now when it says
that the result is negative this is an
important concept real quick everyone
that's listening when it says a negative
negative just means that it's less than
zero a lot of times you'll see less than
0 greater than zero all that saying is
whether it's you know negative or
positive you know it's a lot of times
you'll see this little notation and all
they're really doing is giving you a
hint that it's positive or negative so
so yeah so basically if you solve this
you get negative 5n is less than
negative 15 and if you divide by
negative 5 we talked about this a little
bit earlier what happens to what happens
to the sign when you divide by negative
it flips so n is
than three so that's the idea on that
one so yeah so other questions other
things you want to ask I think what I'm
going to do is try to open this open
this up a little bit here see if I can
make a little bit brighter in here sit
this way a little more light it'll be
easier to see okay just a second oops
disaster oops I was pulling the blinds
and it fell okay well it is brighter now
okay so yeah so other questions
okay so soccer has said can you go over
the first 10 questions on the a CT math
it's a good question I don't have those
right in front of me right now so maybe
if people have some specific questions I
can answer those or if you have just
questions in general about you know the
math the acct math section we can talk
about those so anybody else want to jump
in with the question what do you think
so is everyone taking the test on
Saturday so if you haven't subscribed to
the channel yet consider you know
consider subscribing to Mario's math
tutoring YouTube channel and there's a
lot of videos on there I've got over I
think if they got over about 400 videos
right now covering all different
concepts in math as well as a CT math
SAT Math so definitely check those out
Angie's saying that she takes the a CT
to Saturday okay and this is very
helpful okay good
Cesar's saying why did you set that math
problem less than zero oh that was just
a that was just one where they said it
was negative
Cesar they said that the difference
between and 5n was negative so that's
why it was less than zero that's why I
set up that way yeah good question so
what do you what do you think everybody
have some more questions about the a CT
math okay okay Cesar got that one so
again you know I'm available for online
tutoring if anybody's interested in that
you can find out more on my on my
website Mario's math tutoring com or you
can you can text me or email me about
that if you have questions if you're
interested in some private math tutoring
it's a little bit more
then this is this is a little bit a
little bit limited because we're not
really talking face-to-face like we
would on like a Skype call or something
like that so definitely if you're
interested in private just one-on-one
tutoring you can contact me about that
but I really recommend my huge a CT math
review video course it's available for
sale check that out ok walrus ends
another question a dog needs 7 cans of
food in 3 days at this rate how many
cans of food is a dog eat in 3 plus D
days o walrus you've got good questions
you know this is an important concept
it's talking about proportions okay and
proportions is definitely something you
want to understand for the AC T so
you've got 7 cans of food and three days
how many cans of food does a dog eat and
three plus D days see when you set up a
proportion you know it's a ratio equal
to another ratio so like a fraction
equal to another fraction right so the
key here is is that I've got amount of
food per day amount of food per number
of days right so I've got food in the
numerator days in the denominator I do
the same thing on the right so our goal
really is to you know solve for X here
that's the unknown so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to cross multiply
remember you cross multiply when you
have a proportion like that so I get 7
times 3 plus D and the nice thing about
that is it eliminates the the fractions
so I'm just cross multiply on the
diagonal right okay sk-10 RBI says can
you call me Jason okay instead of my
username I also have another question to
ask related to the a CTA was in my
previous prep yeah so yeah definitely
you can write these questions and Jason
I'll try to remember that you just say
people's usernames because it's hard for
me to remember some of this other
information but let me see if I can just
go ahead and now and what we want to do
is we're solving for 4x right so
basically I'm going to I'm not even
about Oh distribute here I'm just going
to divide both sides by 3 so you can see
that we were solving for x so it's going
to be let's see 21 plus 7d all divided
by 3 so your answer is going to be some
version of this right here okay so
that's what we were solving for so some
version of this so did that answer your
question about that one about
walrus I think you're asking about this
one so yeah so other questions other
things you guys and gals want to talk
about for the ECT math section okay
walruses yeah that makes sense thanks
again okay you're welcome so yeah you
guys are asking really great questions
all very important I cover all these
concepts and many many more and that
huge a CT math review video course so I
encourage you guys to get that if
anybody's listening and they've taken
the course feel free to chime in about
that I know sometimes I've done these
live streams and some other students
have told me just while we were
live-streaming that you know about how
it helped them and how many points that
raise our score by so I would definitely
definitely check that out let's see so
hmm let's see Angie sing each day lower
bikes to school in the morning bikes
home in the afternoon okay this sounds
kind of like a distance equals rate
times time problem but I don't know I'd
have to know a little bit more about
that one so if you can let me know more
about that we can do that one so other
questions
let's see soccer head said who watched
the Champions League yesterday okay
let's try to keep this math the math
related I think we're going to you know
see how far this goes I don't want to
drag it out I guess if people are
getting bored we can always wrap it up
at any point but if you still have
interest and ask me some questions we
can do these let's see Angie says if she
bikes at a speed of 12 miles per hour in
the schools three miles from her house
how long does it take her to bike to
school and back whoo that's a good
question okay Nico's saying laugh out
loud you know the thing about these it
sounds like Angie it sounds like this is
a distance equals rate times time
problem okay and this is another
important formula and that was kind of
the theme of this live stream was you
know what are some important formulas
for the AC T mass section and this is
another important formula distance
equals rate times time so let me see so
she bikes at a speed of 12 miles per
hour that's a rate okay and the school
is three miles away so that's the
distance and then this is the time right
so if we solve for time let's see 12
miles per hour and the distance is three
miles so basically it's going to take
her / toeside by 12 right I'm trying to
read the chat and
solve this problem at the same time so
it's taster basically a quarter of an
hour but since she's going there and
back Angie that's going to be double 1/4
so it's going to take her 1/2 hour total
to go there and back so did that answer
your question Angie Angie awx
so basically a distance equals rate
times time question all right Jesse
Jesse Jambo has a question here about
slopes ok and definitely no slope is an
important concept to know for the AC T
and what's even also important maybe
even more important is knowing the
slope-intercept form the y equals MX
plus B form of a line okay Angie says
yes I understand now thank you ok you're
welcome so let's see so Jesse's giving
us this equation here X plus 2y equals 5
minus X plus y and so here's the thing
Jesse what you want to do to solve this
problem is you want to put it into this
form right here y equals MX plus B so
there you know on the AC T they're kind
of testing you on do you understand
those key concepts from your math class
or the things that they feel that you
should really understand and one of them
is slope intercept form so we have to
rearrange this to solve for just Y get Y
by itself on the left and then of course
the number in front of the X okay here
that's your slope so if you guys and
gals want to do that one and let us know
what it is we can certainly do that I
can do it here too if you want if you're
just joining live stream right now
welcome and we're just doing some
formulas and some problems and some
concepts that are covered on that a CT
math section and I know the AC T's
coming up for a lot of students this
weekend on Saturday and I'm also
encouraging everyone to purchase my huge
a CT math review video course and that's
available for sale on my website at
Mario's math tutoring com it's also for
sale through the link in my about page
in my youtube channel that's Mars math
tutoring and it's also available there
should be a link in the description of
this livestream can somebody check and
let me know is that link available and
active in the description of this
livestream it should say there should be
a link there maybe somebody can click it
and see if it takes you to the to the
course there's some free previews there
so there's a even if you don't purchase
it if you don't feel that it's right for
you can still get a
that what it's like by watching those
free previews but here we're just
solving some problems so feel free to
jump in on the chat if you have a
question or something you want me to
talk about or answer the more specific
the better but we're all just trying to
kind of help each other out here on this
live stream and see if you can OKs shin
says is the answer negative two thirds
okay let's see Carlos says yes it is
Miko says yeah it works oh the link
works Miko okay great okay okay Jesse
says no it doesn't work
mm can you guys tell me if that link
works in the description see if that'll
take you over to the video course if not
go to the link in the about page on my
youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring okay but let's see
if we can solve this I know I've been
okay Angie says yeah doesn't work okay
good thanks Angie Walter says it works
okay thanks for checking appreciate it
yeah so go on over there maybe after
this live stream and see if that's
something you're interested and go ahead
and get that get that review video
course I spent a lot of time putting it
together trying to figure out the most
important questions to cover and go
through a bunch of examples together and
that kind of thing a lot of students
have said it's been really helpful so
what I'm going to do is I'm gonna get
the Y's on the on the Left so I'm going
to add Y to both sides so that's going
to be 3y I'm going to subtract X over
here so that's going to give you
negative 2x okay like that and we still
have the positive 5 and the limit I'm
going to do is divide everything by 3 so
if I do that see the number here in
front of the X that's your slope once
you get the Y by itself y equals MX plus
B so negative 2/3 is our slope and so
did that answer your question I think
Jessi was asking that one did that help
Jessi what do you think is that a did
that answer your question Jessi yeah
okay all right so what do you think do
other questions other things you guys
and gals want to talk about other AC t--
math questions let's see okay so any
other questions you guys want to talk
about or discuss so what do you think if
you're enjoying this live stream maybe
consider giving me a like or a thumbs up
if you're not liking it give me a thumbs
down you know whatever whatever whatever
you think just giving your honest
opinion about this live stream
if you haven't okay Christopher is
asking about the percentage probability
formula okay that's a good question
Christopher let's see mark ela says of a
B and C are positive integers such that
a to the B power equals x and C to B
power equals y then what is x times y
equals okay soccer head says let's go
over some more yeah so if you haven't
subscribe to my channel
consider subscribing and then if you
like this video consider giving a thumbs
up so I'll know that you guys enjoy this
and we can do more of these and Jessie's
asking me how about it how did I make
myself so good at math that's a good
question well you know I just I enjoy
math it makes sense to me you know I do
a lot of practice and you know I work
with like a lot of students on a daily
basis most of them in person but I do
work with some students online as well
so it's just a lot of practice you know
but I mainly like seeing students you
know improve and kind of reduce some of
their stress levels and you know boost
their confidence and just raise their
scores overall so that's kind of what
gives me the most satisfaction is just
helping students but just a lot of
practice as you do it more you'll you
know once you learn something it's easy
but before you learn it course is
difficult right but let me see if I can
go back in that chat so there were some
questions here so Christopher was asking
about the probability formula
yeah Christopher that's a good question
you know the main thing with probability
I think I wrote it down here earlier is
probability it's remember it's the
number of successes right so it's what
you want okay over the total possible
outcomes the total things that can
happen so a number of successes over
total possible that's that's your
probability formula and you can leave it
as a fraction you can change it to a
decimal and sometimes it will even ask
you what's the percent chance and you
can convert it into a percentage so
let's see other questions I think
let's see mark Keela if I'm saying that
correctly
asked the pretty tough one I'm not sure
if I know this one but let's me so I can
get another sheet of paper here so let's
see some archaeal is saying if a let's
see hope you're not trying to stop me
here mark ela that's as it looks like a
tricky one so this is and also C to the
B power equals let's see let's see an O
and Christopher's also asking about the
Greek symbol for some in the front okay
we can talk about that to the summation
formulas that's a good question I'm
trying to look quickly at our keyless
formula and then she's asking what's
x times y equals what right question
mark okay so let's see so hmm so if a B
and C are positive integers okay I
missed that part and then an a to the B
equals x and C to B equals y then what
does x times y equal Oh
okay so there you go so x times y so x
times y would be a to the B times C to
the B but here's the thing since they're
both raised to the B power
markula this is going to be a times C
all to the B so do they answer your
question so this is really testing you
on the rules of exponents see that's
that's the thing you know went with the
AC T they try to hit on a lot of
different topics and so rules of
exponents is another important concept
something that I covered them and the
review course I was talking about
earlier so yeah I definitely check that
out we definitely talked about the rules
of exponents okay Christopher was asking
about let's see the Greek symbol with
okay so he's talking about the summation
formulas okay so let's look at those
summation formulas so summation is like
this right okay and so basically this is
the Greek letter Sigma and say for
example you have I equals 1 to 5 right
and let's say this is a 2 I squared
minus 2 okay I'm just making something
up here
basically what this is this called the
index and what you do is you put one in
you simplify this and that's the value
of your first term then you put 2 in you
simplify this that's a value or a second
term 3/4 and you work your way up to
this top number 5 and then you add all
those together and that's your sum now
as this number gets larger and larger
there's formulas to make this summation
you know finding the sum a little bit
easier whether it's an arithmetic sum or
whether it's geometric you know in
nature like we were multiplying and
there's some other formulas as well but
there's only a few terms like in this
example I probably would just put them
in 1 2 3 4 or 5 you know it's and
simplify each of those and then add them
all together and that's your answer but
summation I have more formulas that want
more form as more videos on my mario's
math tutoring youtube channel talking
all about summation notation geometric
series arithmetic series so if you want
to learn more about that that I would
send you over there there's a lot of
good videos
let's see what other questions do you
have let's see I hope I'm answering
these for you let's see let's see sales
for business for three million dollars
let's see so mark ela I hope I answered
your question for that last one
let's see Jason's asking sales for a
business worth three million dollars
more than the second year than the first
and sales for the third year were double
the sales for the second year okay if
sales for the third year were 38 million
dollars what were sales and millions of
dollars for the first year okay okay and
then okay okay so good good okay so
that's a good question you know that's a
really good question you know what I
would do with a question like this one
Jason is I would probably diagram it out
first of all so basically what it is
let's see you've got sales for business
for three million dollars more the
second year than the first so say this
is ax right then that means this is X
plus three million right and then what
the sales for the third year okay that's
this one over here we're double the
sales for the second year so then this
one over here is going to be double
right so it's going to be double this so
two times X plus three right so if sales
for the third year we're 38 million
dollars what were sales and millions of
dollars for the first year
okay so we're altima trying to figure
out the first year but they tell us that
this third year is equal to 38 so all
you have to do is solve this equation
Jason just divide both sides by 2 that's
going to be 19 subtract 3 that's going
to be 16 so then if you put that back in
here to this this over here and then my
diagram basically you can see the first
year they're going to be 16 million so
sometimes it helps to diagram them out
and that you know that's a good
technique as well they give you a room
on the AC T over to the right of the
question so I would draw a diagram that
I try to write an equation and solve it
but you know it's a time test so you
know sometimes you're better off just
taking the answers and back substituting
and checking to see which ones work you
know a lot of times people that watch my
videos like other math people at math
tutors not students they criticize they
say well why are you showing them the
long way well I like to show all the
different ways
then let's students kind of decide which
is going to be the best for them but
sometimes just back substitutions is a
quickest so you might want to consider
that so let's see Angie let's see Angie
saying would you use identities like n
times n plus 1 over 2 okay that's a good
question and soccer hat says I'm going
to watch your other videos yeah there's
a lot of great videos on my youtube
channel
Mario's math tutoring elite gamer says
hi ok welcome to the live stream so if
you guys are just joining us consider
subscribing to the channel give me a
thumbs up on this video if you're liking
this this live stream and consider
checking out that huge a CT math review
video course I have for sale through the
link in the description of this
livestream it goes through 65 concepts
it's three and a half hours of video
it's got tons of information there are a
lot of students have benefited and
boosted their score on the a CT math
section and if you're interested in
online one-on-one tutoring and you want
to you like my style and my teaching
style and if you want to work with me
you know whether it be for one session
or more than one session or we can talk
about that you can reach out and contact
me and we can certainly do that if
you're interested in that and yeah so
basically that's basically it so let's
see if Angie just try and answer your
question here you're just asking about n
times n plus 1 over 2 you know what this
formula is angie is basically like if
you're adding up consecutive integers
like 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5 plus
dot dot n like that right so if you were
adding up all the integers from 1 to 100
say for example what you would do is
you'd say well the first term is 1 okay
so that's your one right here okay your
last term is 100 right there's a hundred
terms and divided by two so that's the
idea so this is finding up the sum of
consecutive integers yeah so the formula
again is a this is the first term and
this is the last term and this is the
number of terms divided by two okay
let's see Miko has a question at a
picnic one junior and one senior are
selected if they're 125 juniors and 100
seniors what is the possibility to have
a combination of 1 to 1 hmm let me see
I'm not sure if I understand the
question exactly different combinations
oh how many different combinations are
there ok I Phi ok Miko you are touching
on a very important concept and this is
called the multiplication counting
principle or it's also called the
fundamental counting principle and this
is important you know this is important
for the AC T mass section you want to
know how to work with the fundamental
counting principle and so to answer your
question there's a ha let me see if I
can bring it back up again so there was
125 juniors and there's 100 seniors and
so if you pick one junior and one senior
you have 125 choices for who you pick to
be the junior and 100 choices to pick
for who's going to be the senior you
multiply those together that's how many
ways you could pick one junior and one
senior and so that's going to come out
to what 12,500 right so that's how many
how many there is so that's called the
multiplication counting principle so if
you're just joining us right now we're
kind of getting near the end of this
live stream I encourage you to subscribe
to the channel so you can find out you
know notifications when I release new
videos or when I go live with these live
streams
let's see Danielle's asking a question
and then let's see also I want to see if
you guys would be interested in liking
the video if you're enjoying this
Marketo is asking about shading for
inequalities okay that's a good question
mark ela and let's see what else do I
want to encourage you guys to do I
really want to encourage you guys to
check out my huge a CT math review video
course that's for sale and you can go
through the link on that in the
description in this video or through the
my about page I have a link there too on
my youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
let's see so definitely get that get
that huge see if I got the right name
huge a CT math review miko saying thanks
oh you're welcome a huge a CT math
review video course ok and this is this
is with me k ha markula says you're 21
passive video is really helpful as well
okay thanks mark you'll I appreciate
that that 21 concept video course is
really just like an introduction to this
course that would just kind of went
through 21 pass ups this one goes
through 65 concepts it's over 3.5 hours
of video okay and has lots of examples
we go through a teaching section we go
through some sample problems for each of
the different topics you have an
opportunity to practice and we go
through them together it's it's just
loaded with information a lot of
students have contacted me and said you
know what a difference it made in their
their scores on that test so I encourage
you to get this course if you're at all
interested this is with with Mario's
math tutoring that's me Mario's math
tutoring you can you can get the links
through the description or on the about
page on my youtube channel and let's see
what else do I want encourage you to do
if you're if you don't want to do that
that's okay that's completely fine I do
have more videos just talking about
let's see some previously released a CT
test so you can check those out on my
youtube channel and kind of see how I
work through some of the different
problems there on the whiteboard oh and
I also want to see if you're interested
in online tutoring you can contact me
through my website Mario's math tutoring
com.com and or if you want to do like a
FaceTime or we can use the online
whiteboard that I that I generally use
we can see each other in live time and
we can we can share the whiteboard and
right there together and work through
some problems or if you have some
specific questions or concepts that you
don't understand we can talk about those
so feel free to reach out to me about
that I'll take just one last maybe look
here about the the live stream here the
chat see if there's anything else that
we want to talk about here I know there
were some other questions danielís had a
question about how many rubber bands
will she need in order to stretch a
different rubberband across every
possible pair of nails
oh that's if men cuts a board in the
shape of a regular hexagon and pounds in
a nail at equal distances from each
vertex oh I kind of like that promises
but it's an interesting it's like a
geometry because you know on the AC T so
you know on the AC T what do they do
they ask you questions about
algebra geometry algebra 2 trigonometry
not really much in the way of
precalculus so it's basically you know
pre-algebra algebra geometry
trigonometry like that so but let's see
if we can do this one for din Daniela so
it's basically we've got a hexagon right
so hexagon like this right okay so you
basically here's the here's the vertices
those are the corners of the hexagon
right six sides and so you're trying to
stretch these rubber bands you know like
this and you're wondering you know how
many different rubber bands you know can
you so I guess I'm drawing them right
now I guess you could count all these
but that might take a little while all
right you know just keep keep going from
one one to the next like that and you'll
count them all up but let's see is there
an easier way to do it well that's a
good question so basically it's it's
really like this it's a six choose two
so it's saying out of these six vertices
how many ways are there to choose to
where the order doesn't matter so if I'm
pairing up this one with this one or
this one with this one that's the same
rubber band that's connecting those two
nails okay and so if you know your again
this whole live stream is basically
dedicated I guess in my viewpoint and
two formulas we were kind of talking
about what kind of formulas you need to
know for the for the AC T and the
combination formula is this one right
here it's n factorial over n minus R
factorial our factorials so if you want
to go over combinations you can check
out more videos on my youtube channel
tomorrow's math tutoring but in this
case you can see n is 6 and R is 2 so
this would be 6 factorial over 6 minus 2
factorial 2 factorial and so let's see
so we simplify that down that's 6
factorial over 4 factorial 2 factorial
and remember the way these factorials
work you start at this number and you
multiply down so you get to 1 right same
thing here 4 3 2 1 and same thing with
the 2 factorial 2 times 1 so look we got
a lot of cancellation that's occurring
here I'm just crossing these guys out 2
times 1 is 2 and let's see 2 goes into 6
3 times so it looks like there should be
50
so Daniella says where did you get the
two from okay yeah this is your question
wasn't it Daniella well where I got the
two from is that you're pairing up okay
backless chaps to say which type of
problems show up the most on the ACMs
section oh that's what we're talking
about right now we're talking about you
know what what are some important
formulas and we're talking about some
different questions that you could see
on the you know on the a CT math section
but yeah basically you're pairing up two
at a time so out of six vertices how
many ways are there to choose to where
the order doesn't matter so that's a
combination as opposed to a permutation
where the order does matter so did that
answer your question Daniella if you're
just joining the live stream right now
subscribe to the channel you know so you
can be alerted more math videos that are
released or if I go live with some more
live streams like this so you can be
notified like the video is it always -
Danielle well it depends like you know
it depends on the type of problem for
our like in this case if you're just
choosing two vertices to connect with
that rubber band that's that's - you
know if you're trying to make triangles
then you'd be choosing you'd be choosing
three vertices to make a triangle you
know so it kind of depends on how many
this is the total and this is how many
you're choosing out of that total so
yeah so yeah so basically yeah I'm
basically just trying to help students
out a little bit here today we've been
kind of going a little bit long usually
I try to keep the live streams to about
an hour but we can go a little bit
longer if you're interested but let me
know elite gamer says hi okay thanks for
joining so if you're just joining us
here now we're just talking about a CT
math subscribe to the channel if you
haven't subscribed already like this
video if you're enjoying this live
stream and again let me just remind you
that you know I'm available for online
math tutoring if you're interested in
that for the a CTE or the SAT or just
for a math class and then let's see I
also wanted to tell you about the huge a
CT math review video course that's when
I was talking about with it earlier so
check that out in the link in the
description to this video
that's it goes through 65 concepts three
and a half hours of video and of course
you know you can pick out the important
parts that you want to go over and skip
some of the others but each one of those
lessons is just loaded with great
information example problems so each one
of those concepts potentially can raise
your your score by one point so if you
haven't scored as well as you wanted to
this might be something that could can
help you boost your score so definitely
check that out
either on my website or let's see let's
see Joseph's asking a question any
advice for dividing the time allotted
for the math section so as to be the
most successful
Joseph Perez that's a good question you
know this is my take on that you've got
60 minutes right 60 minutes and you've
got 60 questions so if you're a
mathematician you would say well that
means that's one minute per question
right but aha
generally the questions at the very
beginning of the test are simpler so it
should only take you maybe like 20
seconds or 15 seconds to do some of the
ones in the very beginning and so if you
can get through those a little bit
quicker they'll save some time for you
at the end of the test work on some of
those tougher problems they tend to get
a little bit more difficult as you get
past number 30 or so I would say they
tend to get progressively more difficult
so the first ones you don't want to
overthink the ones at the very end you
don't want to under think and take for
granted so you wanna make sure you're
checking your answers but basically if I
can answer your question at my opinion I
would try to go a little bit quicker at
the beginning but then again you don't
make simple mistakes because each
question is worth the same one point
right so you know it's basically worth
weighted the same no penalty for
guessing you know if you don't know you
can always take a guess but up but as
far as the timing the pacing I would
take some practice tests you know maybe
take a look at the yeah backless champs
is saying I'm stumped on one question
should I skip or guess well I would
guess you know you maybe put a little
mark in your booklet so you can go back
to that one if you have time and you can
work it out a little bit a little bit
further but yeah there's no penalty for
guessing and you know you might as well
you might get it might get a few extra
points by doing that so any other
questions I know we're running cutting
along on this live stream what do you
think has this been helpful has everyone
gotten some good benefit from this I
sure hope so
I had a little bit of time so I thought
I would jump here on line and let's see
the elite gamer says hi I live near your
area and I was wondering if you could
give me some math less
as I'm struggling with the subject yeah
you can contact me if you want to talk
about that just you can reach me through
my website Mario's math tutoring com
Angie says it's been great okay I'm glad
you guys joined us Angie and Joseph I'm
glad you joined us he's saying it was it
was great so I think what we'll do is
we'll wrap it up for today and
Christopher says whoo-hoo-hoo okay so
yeah great so yeah I would check out
this a CT math review video course let
me know what you think report back if
you if you think of it I have to take
the a CT and let me know how this
particular livestream maybe helped you
with the a CT and if you take the video
course let me know how that helps you as
well so we're going to wrap it up for
today but again go to my youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring a lot of other
videos on there to help you prepare and
again if you're interested online to
your tutoring contact me and if you're
interested in this this AC T course
check that out as well
otherwise we're just going to call it a
day so enjoy the rest of your day and
good luck on the test on Saturday okay
all right we'll see ya bye